على ملعب تنطلق اليوم اولى مباريات الدور
نصف النهائي من مونديال قطر الارجنتين
وكرواتيا هذه المباراه الثالثه التي تجمع
المنتخب بين في نهائيات كاس العالم
الفريقان تجاوز الدور السابق بركلات
الترجيح امامه هولندا والبرازيل وفي حال
وصول المباراه الى ركلات الترجيح من
المحتمل انه نشاهد مباراه اخرى فاكله
الحارسين بارعين في التصدي وكرواتيا لم
تخسر ابدا في تلك الركلات في مشاركاتها
بالمونديال ميسي يريد هو اللقب الاهم في
مسيرته الوحيد الغائب عن انجازاته اما
الان والا انتهى لا فرصه اضافيه ومرتش
قائد كرواتيا يريد تعويض خيبه امل مونديال
روسيا عندما خسر فريقه امام فرنسا في
النهائي لكن ليكن صريحين القصه كل القصه
هي ميسي هل يتوج ميسي في اثمن جائزه على
وجه الارض قبل ان ينهي مسيرته الموندياليه
اعتقد ان النهائي هيبقى المغرب والارجنتين
كلنا كعرب نفسنا المغرب طبعا ياخذ البطوله
المغرب عامله
[موسيقى]
النهائي باذن الله باذن الله المغرب هتحمل
كاس العالم